so that's a good question like how do
people usually get into p.m. I try to
get into p.m. did you know I mean I try
to get into heart p.m. Facebook or 8:00
p.m. at Google I didn't get those roles
but then if you don't get those roles
how do you get into yeah so I'm English
- yes are there two ways that I think
like people can get into the product
right like the one is like joining a
program or it's like there is no there's
no prerequisite for how much experience
you have so like all the big companies
have rotational program to their product
the problem is is there is like because
there's no prerequisites there's 20,000
people applying for ten slots right it
was like it's like almost like harder to
get into the college that into getting
these roles it is akin to college before
we continue this video I just want to
say thank you so much to our table for
sponsoring this video
our table allows people and companies to
create their own custom applications
regardless of their technical skills
millions of people use our table to
build their own custom software use
cases ranges from product management to
major video productions so that means
that air table can be an all-in-one
platform for product managers what would
you make if you had the tools design for
the way you would like to create air
table gives you the freedom and
structure to design a workflow that fits
your needs our table can handle all
kinds of content that you throw at it
attachments long text posts checkboxes
and just so much more with the air table
you and your team can ID eight organize
and execute on your ambitious product
vision all in one place quickly glance
at a high level progress on all your
initiatives or drill down to any
specific details and understand how to
unblock your projects air table is an
all-in-one collaboration platform that
keeps up with even the fastest growing
product teams now if you're interested
you can receive $50 of credit by signing
up on air table comm slash Joma all
right have you ever used air table
before I have I actually when I was
working a box we actually worked with
really air table to build an integration
we had Howie the CEO come in and talk at
our Friday lunch
but in general I was when the company
was really small but now it's like been
growing like crazy
okay welcome to the show man this for
the wine yeah yeah yeah all right so I
brought you in today because you're a
product manager at Fang right so why
just give me a short deduction yourself
yes Andre
I've been bad at p.m. for maybe four or
so years I studied I grew up in the park
I studied management science engineering
Stanford did a couple startups journey
what I was interning so I did one at a
company called Smule which is a social
music company most famous for the I am
t-pain app on the phone the first one to
use the microphone as an instrument
second our katakana got a reputation
calm more like a privacy tech company
they did a little bit of more data
analytics at work in my junior year I
decided I wanted to see what best
amazing was all about all I've been sold
out for a little bit in the summer I've
been investigating a Mormon Stanley is
that when you started following
arbitrage Andy yeah baby
I definitely understand those jokes but
I just realized at that point it just
wasn't necessarily kind of right for me
there was a lot of like client service
tech works here to work on behalf of
someone else instead of building your
own things yourself and there's other
jobs I was realized that like becoming
being a p.m. is all about like building
things and I wanted to get back to
building things and so that's kind of
where I was and I was kind of the goal I
want to get through is like how do I
start the way of having people yeah
so the first Pam job would be where yeah
first time job I had was at box
haha but I didn't start with you and
then your second PM job is that
basically okay
nice who have you worked with Facebook
awesome at Facebook this one to 10
alright got stuff that you can see I see
the truth I'll just let it all the bad
stuff okay so I'm just gonna stick to
the script this time because a lot of
people tell me that I talk to mushrooms
interviews like shut the [ __ ] up Jonah
unless it the script alright okay so
what does it feel like to be Silicon
Valley's most eligible bachelor but and
you either speaking those words that
make no all my viewers are like oh my
god alright let's get to the real p.m.
stuff so yeah so you told me that he did
I meant backing and then you switch to
p.m. right right and before I eat you
were telling at the analyst how you did
at oh thanks it was mostly work that's
tech startups so was box the first
full-time job
you serve - you were at the analysis yes
I actually did a lot of systems there's
a lot of different things of box I
joined see and I was like a scrub up
with them box I did it like I did
developer marketing I did partnerships
at a analytics I did cause this edge it
because a small team everyone I took
kind of work on everything a box yeah
house is a small company you know when
the team within them says helping build
out our developer a lot more and see and
so it was like probably five or six
people within that whereas our own
business defense so I ended up doing
kind of all the ranges of work just
based on what we needed but wasn't and I
did product stuff but I wasn't a product
manager ok but I can't you were coming
but then but what I did was I knew I
wanted to do
but I guess if you notice in generals
there aren't any roles especially for
people that are coming without p.m.
experience yeah so that's a good
question like how do people usually get
into p.m. I try to get into p.m. did you
know that yeah I know I tried to get
into part p.m. Facebook or 8 p.m. like
Google I didn't get those roles but then
if you don't get those roles how do you
get into yes I mean there's - yes in so
there are two ways that I think like
people can get into the product right
like want is like join a program or it's
like there is no there's no prerequisite
for how much experience you have so like
all the big companies have rotational
program to the product the problem is is
there's like because there's no
prerequisites there's 20,000 people
applying for 10 slots right so it's like
it's like almost like harder to get into
the college that to get into these roles
living in the college do you know the
numbers for rpm APM acceptance no I
think just in terms of sheer numbers
like I would imagine like how many does
a facebook haider I think it's around
like 14 14 14 to 20 minute of every year
or a quarter I think it's almost pretty
it may be increased more but when I
first started I was like 14 per year and
so do you think about it's like it's
like just the numbers aren't in your
favor to start it away like a lot of
people have done it in a way that I tell
people like that wanting it in the
product is like there's two other
pathways one is like you work at a
company and another role and then build
up your kind of background all up your
reputation of the company and then
transition it transition laterally in
the company to product if there's an
opening just because everyone knows your
known quantity people know if you're
doing well like they're more likely to
define the product wrong and the second
one is like you can probably try to find
a really small start-up and start to
just do other things including product
but I would say the easiest way but also
it's not the most direct way is to do
with it
transition into a product role right
and then once you are once you are like
that in the product role it becomes it
opens up a lot of pathways because you
have some experience as a product
manager
so before becoming a PM what are the
best jobs to transition to pick up and
this is not me not being any of like the
the rotational programs but if you start
as a PM right at college like it's great
you become a really good p.m. but you're
really focus not doing something the
first way you've learned it right so if
like Gugu are at Google you look at
Facebook but you learn to do a PM's job
that way and that's what your role what
you think of PMO we think of other
functions and you can be good yeah but I
think to become like a really great p.m.
which I think I'm still working to this
computer is it's almost like it's it's
definitely more I would encourage people
to go work and other functions better
that help support product anyways like
they could be analytics it could be
marketing it could be communication to
be sales right and you build empathy
around like how you should other people
work with product so they become a
product manager you understand how all
these other functions tied together to
become like a really really good product
management sees the whole like picture
right instead of just in their own piece
of building product right but I think
like in general there is no real lloyd
like stepping stone because I don't
think there really is I think like on
the interns on the skills that you want
it's been wonderful my company and
brighter but it depend also depends on
the skills that you want to develop as
if you know cuz there's so many
different types of gems that's true like
one pan can totally have a different
skill set yeah
if you want to be a super technical PM
like yeah it might be really helpful to
have it sweet yeah you might have if
you're a software engineer you work in
data like it'd be really helpful to get
really needed your technical details but
if you're doing something that's more
like consumer facing a little bit
abstract it away like having communicate
good communication skills and being able
to problem-solve and think deeply about
a problem it's like even more important
so if you doesn't matter where like what
job we had before I think the one thing
to note is like you don't like I we've
taken your meter science classes like I
understand like how to code but by no
means I'm technical and so like some of
the best pins that I know are having no
technical backgrounds and they just
learn and they're curious about like
diving deep and understanding a problem
that like it doesn't matter if they're
going to couple skills right okay but if
you have to choose like one job does the
easiest to transition into p.m. let's
say that Facebook yeah because since
you're you're there for a while like
which job do you see most often in
general sit it's offering you see that
there are three types of I think you got
your software engineers talking yeah
there's some software engines that turn
to PMS if they don't if they want to
start like building things and managing
people I don't think it's a it's super
calm and I think data people who are
getting dating and data data like say
the science like having a hair and grasp
about data and how to use to make our
decisions so I think it's in there you
see a lot of people at transition I 20
private twin brother that's also a p.m.
we would not know that 4 p.m. he was an
analytic studies like via scientist and
for then it's easy as you can see the
data trends or at least you know how to
do a pardon one of my policies the other
one is I think even if you're in product
marketing right like you're so close to
any product that like you understand
customer needs so you really have a pen
empathy with the customer or their user
I get much easier to compiègne because
you already have that understanding in
this room because it's so hard to kind
of rate different pants because you're
saying like every panthis really
different things yeah so what makes a
good campus is a great pan like you said
yeah did you know someone that can just
execute well on my vision I like you
have a roadmap you execute one block and
you just march towards up your goal I
think a great PM does a couple things
saying one get help like really
strategize around what is the next thing
that's coming so think ahead of the box
so I get you planned in like six months
like you're working towards that six
month good level you're also
understanding like in the next six
months what do we need it build and so
you're always thinking ahead of how
these products can that can scale
further I think that second thing is
around like just communication I think
if you can communicate and set context
or con different context settings across
like all the different functions and
engineering product marketing privacy
right like I think it makes a light you
like really easy to unlock your team and
getting other people by and understand
why you're doing something I'm gonna say
blasting it's always really helps to be
really floated the data and understand
like honestly riding around queries it's
great to write of course if you can but
I don't do anything when did I had you
okay
I just understand even fluid data so you
see something go up you have to
understand why it goes up and being able
to break apart I can understand exactly
why the love of the lovers are makes you
just really develop your priority to
ition don't understand like this is why
these things are happening is that it's
like not fit just luck
and then it can all be reinforced motion
already later so even that's a good p.m.
you know you say they have to execute
well yeah but it's it's kind of hard to
know I guess for some people to grasp
what what does it actually mean to
execute like the other day right like
well like why is it hard to execute you
just ask someone to do something is easy
right
or is it no it's actually I mean it
would assume as you see there but as
you're working you're not working during
different functions of your event design
or good engineering the data remain the
research and eat for each project that
you have potentially you might have
different tasks for each of them right
and so for maybe your scope you're
starting out a project you need research
and design to start like leave the web
before you can help scope out some
family engineering side and so it's
getting the timelines and land to like
understand what the sequencing of every
project is to make sure everyone's
spending their deadlines and so it's
making sure different teams work
together so that each team have it they
need in order to go build a product and
then once people are building it's like
there's always these roadblocks that
come up and then it's how you unblock
that you that's working with another
team it's like how do you get that team
to do what you want and unblock it your
team to it continue to execute right
like it's a lot of like people
management skills but also just like a
lot of like trying to influence to get
things done
yeah get [ __ ] done so as a great manager
like you are or granny like anecdotes or
actually a concrete things like tips
that you can give to product manager on
how to influence people are how to align
people to better yeah I think
the bigger thing is like it's how do you
set shared bowls it's like if you have
your team is working on one thing with
another team that's working another
thing like if those goals are not
aligned like people are not going to
work together it's us framing a problem
saying like this is the goal we're
trying to do this is how it helps you
this is how what you're doing helps us
make sure they're like everyone's like
alignments and divides to work on the
same thing but those things don't work
then like you always have this fight of
try and like we escalated and say oh
this this like this seems not doing what
we want them to do and it becomes
contentious I see and so I think it's
more about how do you operate a good
working model get people bought into
light what the success isn't saying up
from the successes to make sure and then
the line might commitments they get
people to actually like do things on
time because everything requires a lot
of work and Ross different teams kind of
a each question but what do you think
matters more relationships with these
different teams you can make them do
stuff or incentives I think I have an
you can say one or the other I think
incentivizing a team and through like
the right shared goals builds helps
build a relationship that's wrong
because I mean when I was a data
scientist I did a lot of favors to p.m.
that like more has it you know actually
like so it's not necessary incentives I
feel like I don't know it did sent it to
work as well on me done like
relationship I'm sure it's different but
if you were to say but if you were to
say I like I can help you hit your goal
quicker my angle and if you get exactly
where I said not even personal your team
Riley saying like okay we can get to
this point 20% quicker we thought work
together like that's incentive
the other one is everybody
because once you build that trust like
people are willing to like then spend
timing they know that it's worth it so
you get both how much do you make as a
p.m.
how many out here would be of Allah in
YouTube questions that it varies it
varies I think the one thing good thing
about being a p.m. is that you can you
can make your own like you can work on
things the way you want to work on all
right there's no like I need to choke
this thing by this part there might be a
threshold mm someplace oh you walk
towards but it's not essentially how you
sequence that work and so there's no
like routine day in some days it's like
we have a deadline to hit we work really
hard in other days it's more like okay
we're just scoping out things like we
have time and you can kind of relax and
so I think it depends on the just the
project itself but it's also nice
because like for other roles like if you
go to banking right like you have a
client that need something before you
even start on it and so you're working
hard non-stop and they keep coming in
whereas at p.m. you're managing your own
team and so you can manage those
deadlines in those timelines so it's
much easier I'm sorry I didn't I
couldn't I couldn't get the money you
may have gave me a range so that there's
no it depends on your range it's just
like it elf I have a journal I would say
is the last been a typical software
engineer okay oh yeah that's good that's
a plus there's a most software engineer
but yeah but it's called if F is
honourable do you think it was very
different
you're always a product manager in box
versus Facebook yes like it night Maya
this is vastly different but in two
steps I think one it's like working on
that
versus consumer common and our breasts
company things are dictated more around
like your customers are selling to so as
much it's much more clear about the
things you need to build it's more about
prioritization of it how long it takes
to build and like what the cost is right
because you only have a handful of
clients yeah definitely like a boxy like
seventy five thousand custom and
customer is long but it's like at that
point it's like in under price it's
pretty well known what the problems are
oh yeah they're pretty cool cuz their
pain their pain yes and the goals I
can't even walk can you sell this deal
so it's much easier I'd say like here's
like here's the top things that we need
to do is to close this deal and you
figure out across all your customers or
what you do and you just execute you
build it stuff is it's a little more
technical type problems and there's a
lot more like there's a lot more
stakeholders in it so how is the
interview process like that PN's i
interview processes you can go a couple
ways I think one at a company that's
like big like Facebook or Google and
those in you jet and you are
interviewing for like a general role
right like you're not a team it's pretty
structured it's like you how well can
you break down a product a brilliant big
Lluis product problem like for example
how do you build a better camera I mean
like it's just that's that would be like
the prompt and you have to understand
like how to break it down and put a
framework in place cool the second one
is how well you use data it's like okay
this number is dropping like how would
you deeper get or how would you set a
goal mm-hmm actually before we go into
data can we just make it more concrete
maybe we can make an example so how do
you create a better camera so how would
you answer that if you really yeah I
think the question is is like I mean the
way the structure you usually would take
would be like what is like you would
start out like oh what is the goal of
the whole thing right like what's the
goal of the camera like what's what are
you trying to accomplish and then it's
like potentially exciting like a metric
like what a success for this camera look
like is it selling more as getting
people to use more features right like
mm-hm and then I think it's totally all
about like understanding who the users
are right who are the users and what are
their needs what are they looking for is
it like it's just like a basic
point-and-shoot to capture memories like
people don't care about quality they
care about just the ease and quickness
of like taking a photo
everyone cares about like ridiculous
quality it's like okay maybe it's
something that's a very different right
and then it's understanding like what
are the features that it help address
those needs like what are the things
that you would build and then it's all
about understanding at that point like
prioritization like if you have a finite
set of resources how would you
prioritize something
mm-hmm it's more of like how do you
structure break down that point rather
than what the question or the problem is
yeah that's nice I feel like structure
is really important in these interviews
for example when when you asked me like
oh how do you make a camera better but
then you start breaking down like but
for what you know it is it fit
professionals or is it for like which
which audience because the problem that
people have all the time is they jump
straight to the solutions like all right
camera like the lens or it must be the
quality but there's no way that say like
why are you actually doing it like you
have to really know who your target
audience is exactly and then make sure
in the interview you really ask more
questions right yeah yeah that's a lot
of questions exactly a conversation the
exact cool awesome okay and then the
data side yeah they decided to more like
okay you see numbers going down like why
hmm
or it's like oh you're setting a goal
for your team how would you set that
goal and it's again like how do you put
structure oneboys to in order to like
answer that question because you could
have ton of different goals right like
if you're just a new product like you
might say it's all about user growth
it's a mooring gate if it's more mature
project it's all about like deepening
engagement and so there's like very
different ways you can take it but it's
all about putting a structure in place
to say what the goal is nice I more what
successes and then there's the other
side in other interviews that are
outside of these structured ones around
like okay maybe you're getting hired for
it to be the first game on the team or
higher to a specific role and at that
point it's like it's a couple of things
like how well you can still do break
down ambiguous problems like potentially
high well you can deal with data but
also like do these people want to work
with you and do you have the right
experience to be like to add value to
their team and so it's a little bit more
fungible and if say like okay maybe he's
a little weaker on these places but like
we would think we work really well with
him or we think its perspective is
really good and so it just depends I
guess company to company an older role
how important is domain expertise
usually for experienced PM
and I think it depends on my company
like a company like a big company you
can kind of find any role and so it's a
little bit more generalized but for like
a team that has one headcount for 1:00
p.m. for the rest of the year it's like
it said how do you make the right
decision and having done my expertise
really really does help or really strong
product intuition or a like that
specific space so it definitely does
help do you think you might get
pigeonholed though if it's always about
domain expertise yeah and you see that a
lot I some people who work an enterprise
right like they stuck on there don'ts
not stuck but they built the expertise
around like building developer platforms
and that's just what they keep doing but
I think it is easy to escape and tries
totally different okay I think it just
sometimes easier to keep working a role
they've worked them mm-hmm and the
problem really well do you think you
want to escape your domain or do you
think you want to continue in that
domain whatever no I actually don't know
I think it depends I think I work in
media and I think media is super
interesting and it's also really
challenging I think having firm
enterprise it's like it's a little bit
more cut and dry in terms of the things
that you like and the things that you
should build and so it's just it depends
on like what type of environment you
want I think in consumer it's a lot
about like luck as well because it's
hard to understand what people want and
so it's challenging if you you know you
have to just be patient